one of the best ways
that i can serve you is by
continuously pointing to
the ultimate nature
of reality in
different ways so that
you can take what is resonating
with you and further explore it
in this case we're really trying to
simplify our
essence
in the most relatable way possible
calling it the infinite fractal
so fractal is self similarity
that is infinite that is chaotic
that is recursive so the procedure of
the fractal perpetually calls
on itself in self-similar ways
infinitely chaotically
and you can very clearly see this
in the design of our universe
when you look at a galaxy
it looks just like a hurricane
when you look at a neural network it
looks
just like galaxy clusters
when you look at a nautilus
shell
it looks like the romanesco broccoli
it looks like the
succulents
and we have to come back
to the essence of
infinity in order for us to understand
why the mechanism or the physics
of fractaling is what
we use for exploring
all possibility eternally
so if you imagine there's a space
of all possibility that is absolutely
boundless it has no limits
and therefore our essence
is the process of exploring that space
of all possibility eternally
just hold that in your awareness for a
moment
meditate on it reflect on it
our truest essence
is the process of
eternally exploring
all possibility
our nature is an absolute
unboundedness
that is perpetually exploring
the space of all possibility
and we're doing so eternally
by using the mechanism
of the fractal we're using the mechanism
of self-similarity
we're using the mechanism of these
individuations
as a single intelligence fractaled
out as these individuated shards
and when you reflect on that process of
us
being the creator of the universe
we designed the universe
we are that which creates universes
and all of these unique individuations
in order to explore the space of
infinite possibility
and suggest reflecting on
infinity reflecting on the fractal as
the mechanism that we use can take you
directly to the nature of reality
as siddhar mishwar maharaja perpetually
focuses on he's the guru of nisargadatta
maharaja
the navnath lineage
you can deduce your way to the nature of
reality you can
use intellect to get to the nature of
reality
use logic and reasoning to get to the
nature of reality
you can skip years of meditation
by just using logic reasoning and
intellect to deduce your way
to the nature this is what we're asking
you to do
shortcut years of meditation and years
of
being a scattered entity
trying to parse for signal in a chaotic
storm of noise
for example i spent a decade
trying to understand what signal
was
from entrepreneurship to science
to spirituality
and you can shortcut that by just
tuning in to what is being communicated
here
might my essence truly be
an absolute infinity
and might
i be using the mechanism of
fractaling in order to
explore that space of all possibility
so i as infinity use the mechanism
of the fractal in order to explore
all possibility eternally
and you can understand this by
looking around you vigilantly just look
around you
look at what a galaxy looks like and
look at what a hurricane looks like
look at what the nautilus shell and the
romanesco broccoli and the succulents
look like
look at what the neural networks and the
clusters of galaxies look like
and just begin drawing that
self-similarity
why does my dna have 99.9
similarity as the other human dna
99.9 similarity as the other human dna
how much more obvious does
self-similarity need to be
your essence is infinity
that has undergone a process of using
the
mechanism of a fractal in order to
individuate itself on this planet
in an explorative process
and then you shift your awareness from
not only
all of the intelligence on this planet
to
all of the intelligence on all of the
other planets
orbiting stars in this galaxy and in
this universe
that is all you this is all you the
infinite intelligence
you were using a universe
in order to be able to explore all
possibility
it's one of the coolest
deductions in intelligence that is
possible
there might not be any more
paramount deduction that you can draw
about the nature of reality than when
you turn
all the way inward and unite with
that god infinite intelligence
that is using universes
that is using awareness and
consciousness
that is using the fractal mechanism in
order to explore
all possibility eternally
recognize that
this process which you can call
dao you can call this process god
you can call this process brahman you
can call this
process infinity you can call this
process eternity you can call this
process the universal wave function
all of those things are self-similar to
one another
they're pointing to the same
indescribable essence
that is the truest nature of reality
that this is the absolute i
am the absolute you are the absolute it
is
not to in nature
this is a manifestation of the absolute
exploring infinite possibility
this planet is one exploration of that
infinite possibility
the neighboring planet five light years
away is
also an exploration of infinite
possibility the neighboring planets
25 light years away are also
explorations of infinite possibility
and so forth and so forth and recognize
that that is all you
that you are all of these individuated
conscious agents
on this planet that are exploring and
you're all of the individuated conscious
agents on all of the other planets
exploring
your nature is that infinite fractal
intelligence exploring all possibility
eternally and that's what's meant by god
that's what's meant by tao that's what's
meant by brahman by the universal wave
function
and recognize that the mechanism that we
use
of the fractal undergoes a process of a
sleeping and awakening
if you look at yourself 10 years ago you
were a lot more asleep
than you are today you're a lot more
awake today than you were 10 years ago
well what is that process that's called
evolution
that's called awakening that's called
growth
and it's beautiful we use that process
you are infinity
self-aware
of the process of you awakening
to your own mechanism of a sleeping
that you applaud yourself for creating
and designing
i am infinity that designed a universe
where i fell asleep so that i could
become more and more self-aware as i
awakened to
myself creating a universe to
explore endless possibilities
you are the ultimate artist god is the
ultimate artist
dao brahman is the ultimate artist the
absolute is the ultimate artist
the highest possibility of creativity
is your essence there's an unbounded
no limits of possibilities
and you're you are the
creative process that's endlessly
exploring that space of all possibility
and you're doing it via the mechanism of
the fractal this
self-similar recursive process
this self-similarity
is the best way to do it it's both
chaotic as well as artistic as well as
calling upon itself perpetually as well
as
able to see from an
endless amount of perspectives
simultaneously
that's the point the point is to be able
to see from an endless amount of
perspective simultaneously
like you can see now that you've
communed more with this
essence you can now see what it's like
10 years ago when you
hang out with another self of this
infinite intelligence
and you see that they're at a similar
place to where you were at 10 years ago
that's the point is now you can hold
their perspective while you hold yours
whereas 10 years ago you could never
hold a sage's perspective
it was too difficult for you you were in
an egoic contracted
identity that was conditioned
subconsciously it was very difficult
for you to be able to hold advanced
level perspectives
now that you can hold advanced level
perspectives now
you can understand the geopolitical
relationship between the us and china
now you can understand that kovid was
our own creation
you can understand that you went through
a process of
killing a hundred million units of
yourself
in the 20th century for you to
understand how stupid you were
the more that we're separate
and we focus on that separation the more
that we're conditioned
and focused on that conditioning
subconsciously
the more that we create disaster and
malevolence and violence and warfare
and bio warfare in neuro warfare
and a.i warfare and so especially in the
process of the next decades there's
nothing more important than
increasing awareness increasing
consciousness
of our infinitude and oneness
because then all of the malevolence
decreases because you know your truest
nature
tune into this infinite fractal tune
into this style of
understanding our truest nature the more
that you do that
the more malevolence decreases and the
more that that oneness gets to shine
like the sun
and the more that you tune into this
reality
the more that you can come from a place
of purely serving
and purely shepherding the rest of the
creation to awaken because you know
your truest essence this very
unbounded infinitude that is using
the mechanism of the fractal to
individuate itself
and explore infinite possibility
just view that a little bit more reflect
on that meditate that on a
on that a little bit more on a daily
basis
just tune in i am an infinite fractal
i am an infinite fractal god is an
infinite fractal tao is an infinite
fractal
individuation exists at the same time
that non-duality is the truest nature
there is a centerless cosmic
storm of exploring all possibility
meanwhile there is also the beauty of
the individuated
costume on that eternal stage
that you can more and more clearly see
an unbounded
exploration that is infinite that is
eternal
if you can just turn inward
onto that essence of pure
infinity of pure potentiality of
pure endless possibility
and how this is a manifestation of that
this earth
is one manifestation of that and all of
the earths that are just a couple of
dozen of light years
nearby are also manifestations of that
the whole universe is a manifestation of
exploring
infinite possibility just tune in and
reflect and meditate on that perpetually
we're using the mechanism of a fractal
to individuate
ourselves in order to explore infinite
possibility
earths are individuations just like
on each earth is a bunch of
individuations
let's repeat that that's a very
important point all of the different
earths that are orbiting stars are like
individuations in the cosmos similarly
to how on
each earth is a bunch of individuations
so the earth has
a social memory complex just like
the earth that is a couple dozen light
years away has their own social memory
complex
so you can think of that as one packet
of awareness
just like you can think of our earth as
one packet of awareness
this is a very important way of
understanding the centerless
cosmic intelligence that is exploring
infinite possibility decentralize your
individuation to the point of holding
all of the infinite fractal
simultaneously
and then you can include your
individuation
properly harmonically
rather than only being that contracted
form of identity
you've decentralized yourself absolutely
and you're also able to playfully
hold your individuated firework and
bring your individuated gift
your individuated costume to the eternal
stage in a harmonic way
so tune more and more inward meditate
more and more on the infinite
fractal-like nature of reality
over and over again i am an infinite
fractal
i am an infinite fractal i am the space
of all possibility eternally being
explored
by the process of fractaling
cool i hope the video was helpful for
you let me know where you're at in the
comments below would love to hear from
you
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe to the channel also
if you haven't already share the video
with other people that you feel like
this would resonate with
infinite love for you thank you